[Music]
amen amen
wow i think it's lit can be synonymous
for amen wow i know
and she just wept
[Laughter]
all right
so proud of us bro so proud of us
we created a book
and it's beautiful by the way
it's so beautiful
shout out to serenity amen for making
this uh artwork here
this beautiful stuff here
beautiful
and we'll give you another little sneak
peek into one of them
yes during the show as well one of the
many illustrations
yeah serenity crushed it you and i
distilled a masterpiece my brother we
distilled a masterpiece so short
so friendly
simplify what they what most christians
say it can't be explained yes
because god knows
because the moment that you try and put
this into words it's lost yeah
yeah so i feel like we did what we could
right before that moment where it's lost
yes yeah and and because of
sky has this
rhythm
where
he
weaved in
the
detective mystery yeah style which makes
it super relatable and personal
personable yeah yep this makes me make
makes us or makes you feel like we're
talking to you
and i just felt that that was really
really important
um
i don't know i feel like when i'm
reading books where i feel like the
author
can really like relate to me and see me
then i love it so i feel like if i'm
talking to you as if i'm literally
sitting next to you then it's like
you're not reading a book you're talking
to a friend
yeah
yep
so it's very friendly
also the questions are
which you chimed in missed a question
man
but no atlas just has amazing questions
um thought-provoking questions questions
that
really takes your mind to the edge of
time
and i think that
having those questions was important
because it gave me like an outline to
kind of like weave in and out you know
um because these are questions that
trigger so many responses so it's like i
guess as they're
getting the responses that are triggered
i'm there patting you on the back saying
okay yeah and so
as we continue on
furthermore yeah
yeah yeah
it's it's a beautiful i feel like it's a
beautiful intertwining of the feminine
and masculine energy just in the writing
style and the way we're expressing
throughout this book yeah greed mm-hmm
yep
yeah
oh man what a beautiful process of
several months of meeting every week or
every couple weeks
maybe
total time somewhere approaching 100 or
so hours yeah of total time yeah
and
that
weaving in the incredible illustrations
of serenity weaving in the incredible
detective mystery these really powerful
questions
and keeping it super short and super
distilled and
then
unleashing this as an artistic
expression that then creates these
little waves and ripples to
you guys yeah
and then you guys create these little
waves and ripples to your families and
friends and then before you know it more
of life reality is awakening to itself
the mystery awakening to itself yeah
yeah amen as we express ourselves
yeah it's lit
it's lit
i'm so i'm so grateful skye literally
had a child while we were he had sonny
he had a child while we were
writing this
did we start before he was here
or was it writing it started right
before seoul came into the world yes oh
yeah yeah yeah so yeah right before he
was here we started and then sonnen gave
birth
and then we went on from there and just
had our sessions trying to figure out
how i can get down here and also not
feel like i'm away from my son
yeah and dealing with that but knowing
that this is something that my son will
be able to enjoy we'll be able to read
will be able to digest at an early age
and i did not get to digest anything
like this
until i was like 24 or 25 yes so yes
even though i had a few hours away from
seoul
i was well spent yes you know because
what i wanted to do especially with this
book is simplify
source so i wanted to make like an
adult's
children's book if that makes sense so
good yeah i wanted to make a book a book
where
you're reading it and you're like man
this is so simple
and you keep saying it throughout the
book until the end yeah till you get to
the end and it's like wow so simple in
that
that's gold right there that's gold
that's cool because i haven't had that
experience i haven't had read a book
where it was like wow this is really
simple they put this in such a simple
way and i guess i understand god
[Laughter]
so that's the intention man that's the
intention
to simplify source
into an adult children's book
perfect and then to have every single
one of these lines
every part of this detective mystery and
powerful questions
just
have
the reader go like how do i so quickly
in such a short adult children's book am
grasping the ineffable the mystery
yeah
that's what that's that's if you could
put
the pinnacle of art
into
a process it would be how to take the
ineffable that we are and try and
distill it
try to whether whether it be through
this adult children's books or whether
it be through music or whatever film say
yes exactly whatever you're producing
whatever you're making yeah creating
just weave in the most amount of
awakening possible yeah my suggestion
yeah exactly great yeah
nice so we so what we have planned is we
have we're going to read
um
a couple sentences which we would say is
probably one of the most profound
aspects or realizations yes yeah cool
and then we'll play on that for a bit
as our little promotion by the way you
guys can find the link to
the book
paperback baby
and kindle
in
the
bio
description of this video
and we just finished the audiobook today
which is
and so it's under review and it'll be up
as well the links to that will be in the
bio below
and
[Music]
let's jump in let's do it yeah so i'll
start um and this is a favorite of mine
and it says i
in quotations
can forget itself as the costume
identity
this is arguably the most important
feature of realities
the ability to forget and remember
and um
just simply i love that because
it gives meaning to life and it doesn't
exclude anyone from feeling like they're
not a part of this grand thing
you know like
we're all a part of it and even when you
forget you know and i i would say that
man sitting in nostalgia is a habit that
i gotta break but
it's the times where i was actually the
sleepiest where i knew nothing of any of
this where i felt like
in a way i was i was really happy and
i'm gonna change that because i feel
like i was gonna say the most happy i
don't wanna say that but i would i would
say that i was definitely happy and it's
i don't look back on those moments and
think uh i wish i was awake and then or
i wish i was awake and then i actually
enjoy the moments for exactly what they
are um because ignorance is bliss and
awareness is bliss i realized
and that is the ability to forget and
remember and um it's an ability because
you already know so it's not like you're
just forgetting and remembering at a at
a higher level i guess i feel like it's
it's an ordained thing but um yeah as we
live life you know you'll have your
moment or maybe you have like a uh
anthogen trip or a psychedelic trip or
something like that and it's like
oh wow so great god ba
and then maybe months later like you're
in the most intense argument with a
spouse or like and in those moments you
don't remember the grand realization
that that psychedelic may have given you
and so you forget
and then you have another moment and you
remember and
having that ease
um
less agony
on being nothing
is what i love so
just knowing that you can forget and
remember
um
i feel like it takes that chip off of
our shoulders from constantly feeling
like we need to always be enlightened or
be aware yeah you know
yeah yeah ooh
i love that i love how you said that
ignorance and awareness are both bliss
it's so funny i i've never heard it but
yeah it's such a good way to put it
the sleepiness
was just as bliss yeah as awakeness
because no one was telling you that it
was wrong and this is great and this is
true non-duality exactly exactly the
pursuit of unified perspectives yes
that's what i love
the pursuit of unified perspectives
that's another
now i cannot take credit for that i
cannot um that is a slogan from one of
my favorite clothing brands called a co
so check those check those out and check
those guys out but um yeah yeah well
that's that's a big part of what
simulation this show has been the last
four years is it is that of unified
perspective literally that's so good bro
synthesized science and spirituality
synthesize consciousness and physicalism
right
figure out how to maximize human
potential all this type of stuff it's
great yeah it's like taking the integral
for those that love math you take the
integral the summation of all
perspective yes
boom and there's god
[Laughter]
i love it and then for me a big part of
this
is that
if you really grok this i can forget
itself as the costume identity
this is arguably the most important
feature of realities the ability to
forget and remember if you really grok
that
and this has been talked about in much
metaphysical literature and especially
raw in the law of one
that the very nature of the veil of
forgetting
[Music]
is
potentially the most important
feature of intelligent infinity
so the the best way one of the best
potential ways for intelligent infinity
to do this endless exploration is to use
this veil of forgetting yes yes so it's
like the coolest
tool or mechanism to move forward yeah
yeah wow yeah so that's that's what's
like you explained that with sentences
my heart yeah
no that was great though
that was great
it's so good so the veil of forgetting
is it's it has to be appreciated this is
how we evolve
at least here right now
we we forget and then when we
re-remember it's like where it's us even
stronger
you know so it's like you like you said
it's like the the very nature of the
veil is the most prized thing here yes
yes it's so well said
and one more aspect to that is that it
is a veil-less veil
and that's the non-duality i wish we
would have put that in the book
[Laughter]
another way to say it is the gateless
gate gateless gate exactly yes
and that's why the ignorance and
awareness are both blitz exactly because
there's a veilus veiler gateless gate or
another way that in
zogchen
the buddhist mystic tradition that it's
been discussed is that it is just like
if you look behind my head right now it
is just like
that very thin
line
between the light and the shadow which
you can't even really say
there is a line between the two or
another way it's been discussed is the
back and front of your hand
and so it's literally that close
to each other right that's what the yeah
is yeah it's that close to each other
and so that's why rumi says you go from
room to room looking for the diamond
that's already around your neck and so
when you first you read that line you
read it uh when you're 23 you read it
when you're 24 you read it when you're
26 and then all of a sudden you break
through when you're 28 and you start
sobbing because you've read that lie so
many times
you never got it until now
yeah
absolutely and i feel like every person
who was on this evolved journey has that
moment
that moment of all those prior moments
before and then it's like wow
okay that's what the person was trying
to say
all right
absolutely yeah i love it and
that's why the in the sufi metaphysics
there is the phrase
and it means the unity of all finding
because
sky's experience with finding through
the veilless veil
is going to be different than atlas's
which is going to be different than all
of yours yes and so that's the
uniqueness of this intelligent infinity
undergoing the process of being able to
remember itself through the veiless veil
in all of these unique styles
and costumes in costumes
perfect yes
perfect
this actually just this conversation
alone is just making me realize how
great this book is well seriously
because we
we just broke down one line from our
book look at the intelligent
conversation that we just had from one
line let's continue
yeah that's great exactly
that's that's great that
what you're alluding to is that there's
the potential to basically have what is
i book clubs oh absolutely yeah where
you could break down yeah a sentence or
two or three yes and just begin talking
for an hour about your experiences with
investigating yes that's so good yeah
yeah
what is ibook clubs in your local cities
in chicago
new york london baltimore baltimore yeah
yeah sioux falls south dakota
shout out to sioux falls in baltimore we
love you guys
all right so this where was this one
chapter two
uh it is in because you have three three
okay okay gotcha yeah
so
um
this
second one that we're gonna read is very
very
tightly intertwined with the first one
that we read
and so this is a single line and it just
reads
what
changes when we see ourselves as i
rather than john
and so
and this
also
really
just
warms our hearts so much because
there's a big
change that happens
when we shift through this veilless veil
that
to us
that we've found the unity of all life
and the unity of all existence the unity
of our beingness
and then just yeah that's it that's
that's really it from that that feeling
right there
yeah this whole time this whole time it
was right here
that
we are all one
under the costumes is the same essence
and that
that that is that and then everything we
do from from then on
becomes
more and more infused with compassion
with love
with care
with wholeness
radiating illuminating like the sun like
we serve
we honorably
joyfully peacefully
serve creation awakening without
extracting from it without feeling
unwhole without feeling unworthy without
feeling like we need validation
because we recognized ourselves as the
sun
through those clouds the veils fail
and it's that's it like that's
what happened
and
that
feeling is why we
put this together is to share and
hopefully create more catalysts for that
feeling
so that i underneath the costumes what
happens when we recognize it
what changes when we recognize it when
you see yourself the way god sees
yeah um
i don't
think i could give a better answer or
more
heartfelt rather answer um
[Music]
i guess i would just use one word
and that's everything everything changes
everything changes when you realize that
you're not your name
and what comes with that your culture
and the race and identity
everything changes when you realize
you're not that
because then everything is available
it's like there's nothing out of reach
and then life becomes infinite or at
least it seemingly feels that way in
this body and then
i don't know
and you know remember when we first met
and you asked
basically you asked
if everything was the way it should be
you know
how would we live after that if
everybody wasn't like you know how where
would we go how would we live remember
reaction i said you know i don't know i
remember saying that but because we're
not there yet i was so far away from
that
and now
five years later as i sit here
i can say that
you explore
confidently you you
you explore in so many ways
not just oh let me go to this country or
let me go take this hike
you explore in the most
finite
and infinite ways
i pieced together
details of my life through books and
shows and conversations and how fast the
pigeon flew and
it all just makes sense to me but before
i'm living life like oh i should be i
should go here or do this because my
teacher said this and my mom said you
know just living life in such a normal
way but i literally use all of life to
understand my everyday experience
yeah and
that is what changed
like i'm so much more than just
ah the everyday just i don't know
everything i'm just going to go back to
the first answer is everything
everything changes everything changes
yeah
yeah
man
the shift from feeling like a victim to
the creation to i'm the creator of
creation
uh and then seeing the divinity the
miracle everywhere
i love that everything changes baby
everything changes yes sir and there's
so many relatable ass analogies in here
and the whole thing
just
shifts you more and more into wholeness
into compassion into love
and as you read
yeah and this is a visualization which
you can share now yeah yeah
cool you want to do it so
this is a visualization of a serenity's
design
and
um and this is for
it's cool to say the chapter title yeah
yeah okay cool this is for the chapter
that's titled one infinite creator
and so the visual
looks like
this
[Music]
and that plays into what we've been
discussing
where what is under the costumes
i
is under john is under sky
is under atlas is under you
yeah
and the pictures are important because
we
i feel like
if you look at each one i feel you can
find all in every one every single one
even though every picture is correlating
to a chapter that's leading you to
something
the great thing about source is that
it's all in everything so even in our
expression you can see that and even in
this so like the first the first visual
visualization for the first chapter you
can find god
all the way to the end
and it's
it's seemingly chapters one through ten
but it's really
chapter
yeah
and it's just
it's gonna i hope that it comes off as
one experience yes i do full circle
perfect yeah
yeah and i love the idea that we just
came to in the show which was
book clubs baby yeah please like let's
see the best way to get this stuff out
here and affecting the ones that you
love
is is those book collabs and basically
word of mouth is what we're really
saying you know talking about it you
know having
being a detective in your own life
is so important
and with the people that you love so you
guys go getting together okay what was
this like for you when you did this how
was that like when you realized this
you know how long did it take you or
whatever like this is how we come to our
collective truths
you know but if we don't do this then
we're so divided in the an extreme
amount of ways that we can't even see
the oneness
so
yeah yeah
that's great
use the opportunity of
coming together
around this core question of what is i
to
recognize our collective truth yeah that
one thing to know as is written in the
ig bio one of the most gangster people i
know yes literally because people keep
going around saying i this i that and i
want to i don't want to give too much
from the book but
i this i that who in the hell is i
or rather what
[Music]
yeah but i feel like we gave him a good
dose of what's in the book
things that inspired us why we wrote it
you know the the illustrations and now
it's time for you guys to investigate
just
a civilization running around i i i i i
i i i i who the hell is that eye what is
that no one's asking yeah and that one
question takes you all the way all the
way all the way
should we read the book is that should
we read that yeah yeah yeah okay because
this relates perfectly let's go uh laugh
along yeah you do the first one i'll do
the middle one yeah
this book is a direct investigation of i
our innermost sense of self
using the format of a detective mystery
the authors guide readers through
powerful questions and never once
mention meditation or breath work
go directly to the end using logic
no sitting on a cushion
needed
at all
if it's comfortable
cool
[Laughter]
if you feel the need
all right
[Music]
i appreciate you man me too we are going
to affect the world we our brotherhood
got strengthened so much through this
process
and this is a great way for us to
strengthen our love with each other
through this inquiry and also take on
projects similar to this with one of
your close brothers or sisters and
and meet and then put together a
wonderful piece of art for the world
type stuff yeah absolutely great process
yes sir boom the links are in the bio
below
so
the paperback and
the kindle
is in the bio below check it out support
us support our effort please and
hopefully it'll make a profound impact
on your life your family your friends
community the world
and also like the video because that
ranks it up in the algorithm on youtube
so like the video
and also it helps the algorithm if you
comment below with your thoughts on this
book launch and on what we talked about
so do leave us a comment below subscribe
to the channel if you haven't yet also
share the video as well be like oh [ __ ]
look at this book i just launched look
at this book that just launched and
shared the video
and then also
audiobook link will be in the bio
shortly as well and then also check out
the instagram profiles that are in the
bio so serenity's instagram is in the
bio who is the artist and the
illustrator of these incredible visuals
go and follow her check out her other
work there
and then skye's instagram is down there
and then so is mine out this is so you
can check out our instagrams
and
that is all anything else from you no i
like i said i just want to affect the
world and this book is my book
dedication is to you
source
source
as always
for all time
always always infinite love fam thanks
so much for tuning in and
check out the book infinite love peace